et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
David Corman bonjour si beaucoup d'être
avec nous des petites européens Europe
Écologie Les Verts et auteurs de ce
livre ce que nous sommes repères
écologiste s'est aux éditions les petits
matins on va parler tout au long de
cette interview parce que vous abordez
beaucoup de sujets dans ce livre on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représentée par
Fabrice wesser Redon Jean Fabrice
bonjour Oriane
régionaux de tous l'est de la France on
va parler évidemment de l'Ukraine on va
parler écologie on va parler de votre
livre mais d'abord un mot sur la
disparition de la reine d'Angleterre
David Corman qui aura connu l'arrimage
de son pays à l'Union européenne et puis
le brexit au cours de son règne elle
était le ciment du Royaume-Uni est-ce
que vous craignez que ça disparition est
des conséquences sur les relations entre
l'Union européenne et le Royaume-Uni
d'ailleurs elle est morte elle est morte
en Écosse qui était alors c'est pas un
pays puisque ça fait partie de la
Grande-Bretagne mais qui manifeste sa
volonté de rester ou plutôt de revenir
dans l'Union dans l'Union européenne bon
vous savez c'est toujours particulier
quand il y a le décès parce qu'elle a
connu d'autre chose c'est la reine
d'Angleterre c'est un règne d'une
longévité incroyable c'est la monarchie
c'est l'idée de la permanence c'est ça
qui fait que un peuple s'identifie à son
pays etc enfin pour les pays qui sont
des monarchies et elle a la permanence
du principe monarchique s'ajoute la
permanence de l'Algérie donc la longueur
de son règne de la et je pense que c'est
qu'elle ça qui quelque part peut nous
toucher c'est que ça nous renvoie à
notre propre finitude finalement même
elle même cette permanence là si finit
par s'arrêter mais vous avez raison de
dire que
la Grande-Bretagne rentre dans un moment
de turbulences d'abord parce que y
compris la reine et un carnet ça c'était
le commonwals c'est une puissance
historiquement impériale qui évidemment
c'est moins le cas et au sein même de
l'île de Grande-Bretagne enfin des îles
de Grande-Bretagne il y a la possibilité
notamment suite au départ de la de
l'Union européenne d'un pas
démantèlement mais que certains nombre
de Provins enfin comme l'Écosse
choisissent indépendance vous comprenez
est engouement cette émotion que suscite
cette actualité vous savez j'ai vu tous
les coups en France
[Musique]
j'aime pas juger l'émotion des gens
quelque chose qui est intime je
comprends l'aspect politique je
républicain etc etc c'est engouement
c'est engouement regroupement je sais
pas je pense que il y a ce que je vous
disais il y a une forme de de on la
connaît toutes et tous depuis qu'on est
petit donc elle fait partie voilà de
notre paysage mental donc c'est pas on a
le droit de ressentir de l'émotion y
compris pour des personnages voilà qui
représentent des institutions à laquelle
on croit pas par ailleurs je pense voilà
je pense ça me rappelle la fois vous
êtes en train de rappeler vous n'êtes
pas monarchiste oui mais je suis surtout
en train de me rappeler qu'il faut
laisser les gens ressentir de l'émotion
et encore une fois on peut on peut être
tout à fait lucide sur ce qu'a
représenté ce que représente encore
parfois l'impérialisme britannique où il
est impermé c'est impérialisme
occidental en général tout en voilà les
gens se recueillir en paix son fils
Charles lui succède Charles c'est un
précurseur en matière d'écologie c'est
une bonne nouvelle pour vous un écolo
pour vous pour moi c'est quelqu'un qui
est très sensible à la question
environnementale ce qui est différent du
fait d'être un écologiste c'est pour ça
que loin effectivement il est sensible à
cette question là si j'étais taquin je
dirais que les familles monarchiques ont
du temps de profiter de la contemplation
de la nature donc c'est peut-être ça qui
a fait qu'il est sensible à cela mais il
faut être quand on est écologiste il
faut être sensible faut pas seulement
comment dire il faut être lucide sur les
causes qui génère les destructions qu'il
semble déplorer or voilà le modèle
extractiviste le modèle économique que
remettre pas tellement en question je
pense la famille la royale britannique
ce sont elles les causes profondes pour
vous c'est de l'affichage non je pense
qu'il est sincère dans sa démarche et
tant mieux tant mieux je préfère ça il
en a rien à faire parce qu'il a fait
beaucoup de choses sur l'agriculture bio
etc donc tant mieux ça fait un allié les
choses pour l'écologie
mais quand même ça en terme d'affichage
ça permettra de parler plus d'écologie
mais ça y est on en est plus au moment
où il faut sensibiliser sur l'écologie
c'est recul il aurait été roi il y a 50
ans peut-être ça aurait permis de
sensibiliser les gens là on en est plus
à sensibiliser l'opinion sur l'écologie
on sait bien qu'il y a un problème écolo
donc maintenant faut agir voilà on va en
parler tout à l'heure d'abord un mot sur
l'Ukraine puisque évidemment c'est
important 2e jour de guerre en Ukraine
les forces ukrainiennes ont repris
plusieurs villes aux Russes quelques
3000 km², alors les Russes contrôlent
toujours 120 000 km² du territoire
ukrainien mais les Ukrainiens ont gagné
en 5 jours presque deux fois plus que
les Russes en 3 mois est-ce qu'on est un
tournant de cette guerre j'en sais rien
en tout cas ce que je pense c'est qu'il
faut à tout moment saisir l'opportunité
d'arrêter ce conflit et il faut
l'arrêter non pas dans un espèce de de
position un partout machin mais bien
affirmer que c'est la Russie qui agresse
etc etc et d'abord on nous avait
certains avait dit que au début de ce
conflit que pour en quelque sorte
abréger la souffrance du peuple crânien
il fallait tout de suite céder certaines
manières à l'injonction de Poutine même
s'il disait pas c'est comme ça mais
enfin
la responsabilité avant tout sur la
capacité les questions sur l'aide
militaire à l'Ukraine oui mais là dessus
c'est clair que Jean-Luc Mélenchon s'est
trompé quand il dit vous allez voir en
quelque semaine on se moquant d'ailleurs
des écologistes et des socialistes et
voir quand quelques semaines ça sera
tout le monde le sait bon visiblement et
pas un jour mais je veux pas accablé
Jean-Luc Mélenchon parce que les
premières responsables étaient pas au
pouvoir ceux qui sont au pouvoir depuis
20 ans et on fait preuve de naïveté par
rapport à Poutine c'est pas Jean-Luc
Mélenchon c'est les pouvoirs de droite
et de gauche européen qui gérait la
maison et qui n'ont pas vu et qui nous
ont rendu dépendants vulnérables on va
en parler peut-être à au bon vouloir
d'un tyran qui d'un simple geste en
fermant un robinet nous met dans la
dépendance et dans dans la difficulté
donc c'est eux d'abord les responsables
mais sur le conflit en lui-même je pense
que les écologistes ont bien fait de
dire qu'il fallait venir en aide au
peuple crânien qu'il pouvait se défendre
et qu'il fallait un rapport une force
meilleure pour pouvoir obtenir le fait
qu'un État la Russie ne peut pas se
conduire comme une puissance
impérialiste qui envahit sur ce qui le
décident un pays souverain la
souveraineté des peuples à disposer
d'eux-mêmes c'est une valeur
fondamentale donc il ne faut jamais se
débarrasser quand on est quand on a les
valeurs qui sont les nôtres de gauche et
écologistes Emmanuel Macron et Vladimir
Poutine se sont entretenu justement hier
mais manuel Macron a demandé à Vladimir
Poutine de retirer les armes de la
centrale de zapporigium et Poutine l'a
mis en garde contre des conséquences
catastrophiques des attaques régulières
ukrainiennes contre cette centrale
comment on évite l'escalade fatale et
que peut faire l'union européenne vous
parlez dans votre livre de basculement
pour l'Union européenne quand vous
parlez de cette guerre qu'est-ce que
peut faire l'union européenne sur ce
sujet je parle de basculement parce que
ce conflit a été à la fois le révélateur
et l'accélérateur de nos dépendances et
de nos faiblesses pour ça que c'est une
sorte de crash test sur la question de
l'énergie notamment question d'énergie
mais aussi sur la question du manque de
poids diplomatique et militaire de
l'Union européenne nous sommes un géant
économique la première puissance
économique du monde le premier marché du
monde mais nous sommes un an budgétaire
et nous sommes maintenant diplomatique
et donc nous sommes en par ailleurs à
l'échelle de la planète dans un moment
de on va au pire de ce que j'appelle
dans le livre la géopolitique du fossile
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait les rapports de
force sont guidés par l'accès à des
matières premières dont de l'énergie
mais pas seulement il y a les terres
pour le numérique etc etc et que l'Union
européenne doit opposer un autre modèle
que j'appelle la géopolitique du climat
qui repose davantage sur la coopération
et surtout sur une forme de sobriété
pour être moins dépendant des ressources
et des matières premières et donc être
moins à l'heure actuelle
c'est pour ça que je dis qu'on est dans
ce moment de basculement soit on choisit
de continuer avec une vision de l'ancien
monde d'accaparent des matières
premières et ce qui historiquement le
monde occidental n'a fait que ça depuis
ce qui ne semble pas être le cas à
l'heure actuelle c'est l'Union
européenne parle plus de sobriété
énergétiques c'est pour ça qu'on est à
un moment de bascule et donc je pense
qu'il faut qu'on nous réatterissions
dans nos frontières avec une forme de
utilisation des ressources dans nos
disposons etc ce qui aménagerait des
relations plus saines avec les pays dont
aujourd'hui nous sommes dépendants
c'était le cas avec Poutine c'est le cas
avec les Petro monarchies du Golfe etc
etc est-ce que vous attendez du discours
d'Ursula vanderleyen qui prononcera son
grand discours sur l'état de l'Union ce
sera pour celles et ceux qui nous
écoutent qu'ils ne savent pas forcément
c'est tous les ans la présidente de la
Commission européenne c'est l'équivalent
de la première ministre européenne c'est
pas tout à fait pareil mais voilà fait
un discours sur l'état de l'Union alors
c'est aux États-Unis à ça tous les ans
donc je vois on a dû copier ça mais
c'est une sorte de débat politique
générale et là non plus il y a pas de
vote de confiance à la fin comme on l'a
vu en France bref et donc bah là
j'attends qu'elle prenne partie
clairement sur ce bascule lise voilà le
projet de l'Union européenne la
définition de la paix et de la
prospérité vous savez que c'est la
devise européenne cette paix la
prospérité s'appuyait sur je vous en
parlais diplomatie comment dire
prédatrice
diplomatie géopolitique des fossiles
elle reposait sur une prospérité par
l’abondance il faut avoir une
géopolitique moi agressive
plus sobre et aussi une prospérité plus
sobre donc c'est un changement à bascule
de modèle et ça ça craquera beaucoup
d'emplois en réalité parce que
aujourd'hui le modèle dans lequel nous
sommes enchassés n'est pas à l'avantage
du peuple européen puisque vous voyez
bien la production a quitté l'Union
européenne on produit en Chine et
compris ça nous rend aussi très
dépendant bref donc il y a vraiment un
projet politique global pour être plus
sobre écologiquement et plus intense on
en peut vous l'évoquez justement le
progrès vous consacrez pas mal de place
au progrès dans votre livre il faut le
freiner ce progrès ah c'est intéressant
la question vous allez moi je crois pas
en fait faut se mettre d'accord sur
qu'est-ce qu'un progrès je fais la
distinction mais je suis pas pour mieux
avoir fait ça entre l'innovation et le
progrès ce qui est une innovation ne
constitue pas forcément un progrès vous
parliez tout à l'heure de la centrale en
Ukraine sur le nucléaire est-ce que
nucléaire constitue une innovation
indubitablement c'est une technologie à
l'époque en tout cas qui était une
innovation est-ce que c'est un progrès
pour l'humanité j'en doute j'en doute
parce que les dangers qu'elle entraîne
les risques qu'elles nous font courir
sont pas à la hauteur des avantages
qu'ils procurent est en train de marquer
le retour en classe en grâce du
nucléaire ou l'inverse parce que s'il y
a une démonstration vous voyez là en
Ukraine c'est pas à ce stade les armes
nucléaires qui constituent une menace
mais bel et bien une centrale ce qui se
passe en Ukraine c'est la première fois
qu'un pays équipé de centrales
nucléaires et le théâtre d'un conflit
armé on voit bien les problèmes que ça
pose or nous entrons dans un moment de
la politique internationale où les
instabilités comme nous avons vu en
Ukraine vont se multiplier quelque part
c'est une opportunité pour passer à
autre chose vous nous dites je pense que
toute crise est aussi une opportunité
pour passer à autre chose une manière
générale et d'ailleurs quand on regarde
l'Union européenne à chaque fois qu'elle
a eu des avancées c'était parce qu'il y
avait des momentums créés par des crises
la deuxième guerre mondiale qui est pas
des moindres des crises c'est ça qui
fait mais qui fait qu'on crée l'Union
européenne pour la paix et la prospérité
je l'ai dit et là on est dans un moment
tout mou il y a non seulement ce conflit
il y a eu la crise covid il y a
l'exigence de faire la transition
écologique et donc là on est dans un
moment où l'Union européenne soit se
réinvente pour continuer à avoir une
utilité sociale et politique soit elle
reste sur ses repères d'avant la
recherche aveugle de la croissance le
marché libre et non fossé etc etc et
petit à petit les peuples vont s'en
détourner d'ailleurs ça a commencé donc
il y a un vrai enjeu politique et social
et écologique à redéfinir ce qu'elle
proje européen pour le bien-être ce qui
était son objectif au départ du peuple
européen il y a une question qui se pose
c'est la taxation des super profits
notamment des énergétiques des
énergéticiens pardon Agnès panier
renacher dit vendredi avoir porté auprès
de ses collègues européens une position
très ferme pour défendre une
contribution vous êtes satisfait non
enfin moi j'en ai ras-le-bol aussi je
suis à la commission budget au Parlement
européen justement on s'occupe des
recettes aussi bon
parce qu'en fait pour pouvoir dépenser
de l'argent il faut des recettes ayant
une question politique fondamentale
qu'on pose pas c'est tout simplement ce
que la fiscalité c'est ça c'est qui paye
quand il y a besoin de changement qui
paye la madame medsolla la présidente du
Parlement européen qui est du parti PPE
fait une tribune dans Le Monde où elle
dit qu'il faut moderniser le budget
européen elle ce qu'elle voit dans la
modernisation c'est uniquement la
flexibilité moi je me suis toujours
quand on me dit flexibilité ce qu'on a
besoin c'est d'une fiscalité juste qui
paye or là déjà sur le débat on parle
que des super profits comme si on allait
fiscaliser et encore ils sont pas tous
d'accord pour le faire une fois parce
que c'est des super profits non il faut
sociabiliser les profits il faut
sociabiliser une grande partie des
profits hors la France a été un boulet
dans cette affaire quand Biden
rappelez-vous a dit il faut une
fiscalité minimum des entreprises à
l'échelle mondiale il avait proposé 21%
en France c'est 25 pourquoi il propose
ça parce qu'on appelle des paradis
fiscaux c'est-à-dire des pays qui
mettent un taux de fiscalité pour les
entreprises beaucoup plus 2 3 5 6% il y
en a même à l'intérieur de l'Union
européenne bref et donc là les
entreprises cascafont moi je me domicile
dans ce pays là j'ai moins payé d'impôts
partout à l'échelle mondiale donc moins
de paradis fiscaux qu'est-ce qu'a dit la
France Bruno Le Maire ou là c'est trop
compliqué on va jamais y arriver 15 % il
y a 15 % c'est plus un minimum c'est ça
devient un plafond et donc là avec
Madame panier renaché des pays européens
l'ont fait unilatéralement pourquoi
parce que c'est simple la fiscaliser
qu'est-ce que vous dites vous dites
toutes les marches pas les profits vous
fiscalisez tout ce qui a été vendu dans
le pays pour pas qu'il y ait d'évasion
fiscale ça a été fait à l'échelle de
l'Italie on peut tout à fait le faire à
l'échelle d'un pays pourquoi ils disent
j'en discute au niveau européen parce
qu'elle sait que ça va mettre des mois
ou des années à se faire parce que à
l'Europe pour avoir une fiscalité il
faut se mettre d'accord à l'unanimité on
sait que des pays comme la Hongrie
proche de la Russie ne le feront pas
faire du chantage par ailleurs donc en
fait c'est une façon ça pouvait se faire
à la majorité qualifiée c'est pas grave
à l'échelle de la France et le porte au
niveau européen pourquoi ne pas passer
par la case en France on va le faire
d'ailleurs elle serait plus crédible
pour le porter au niveau européen donc
en fait il y a vraiment une façon de
gagner du temps mais je veux dire elle
pousse le problème
ils ne veulent pas que les riches paient
c'est ça la dernière question vous
parlez de ressources le gouvernement
subventionne aujourd'hui
le carburant à la pompe doit-il
continuer non moi je pense que pour ça
que je suis pas tout de même si ça doit
être en difficulté des ménages bah du
coup on aide les ménages qu'on a besoin
mais il y a pas de raison de
défiscaliser pour tout le monde si vous
êtes riche que vous avez une voiture qui
pèse deux que deux tonnes et que vous
choisissez d'y aller prendre pour aller
chercher votre pain il y a pas de raison
que les pauvres payent pour votre
essence il faut que la solidarité sur en
attendant qu'on ait des solutions
pérennes pour se passer d'une voiture
soit concentré sur les gens qu'on a
besoin on n'a pas beaucoup d'argent
public et il faut mener des chantiers
énormes pour faire la transition
écologique il faut arrêter de balancer
de l'argent par les fenêtres donc oui
bien sûr des aides pour les foyers qu'on
a besoin pour qu'ils soient pas
emprisonnés chez eux qui puissent
continuer à aller au travail mais on
cible sur ceux qu'on a besoin pas pour
tout le monde une incision avant de
parler de votre partie et plus largement
de la gauche est-ce que vous appelez au
boycott de l'équipe de France pour la
Coupe du Monde au Qatar moi je sais que
je regarderai pas voilà je sais que je
regarderai pas parce que non je
regardais avant c'était pour être franc
c'était les seuls matchs de foot que je
regardais parce que il y a pas parce que
c'est non ça me dégoûte en fait je vais
vous dire allez voir des gens jouer au
foot faire la fête et en dessous il y a
6000 cadavres de de vos enfin on se rend
compte de ce que ça fait 6500 personnes
qui sont morts pour construire des stats
climatisés mais on est dans quel monde
en fait ça me donne plus envie c'est pas
c'est pas un appel politique à boycotter
les gens ils ont la télé ils font ce
qu'ils veulent je sais pas mais moi j'ai
pas envie de dormir
trop tard maintenant c'est trop tard
vous savez le y compris il y aurait
réformer la FIFA et la Fédération
Française de foot qui sont quand même à
ramasser de bon bref de gens qui sont
laissés corrompre dans cette affaire
c'est une honte y compris enfin les
valeurs du sport c'est pas ça tout ça
n'a plus rien à voir avec le sport voilà
tout ça n'a plus rien à voir avec du
foot c'est avoir avec d'autres choses
qui m'intéresse pas donc voilà je
n'aurais pas envie de regarder on va
parler de la gauche l'écologie Fabien
Roussel a eu cette phrase ce week-end il
a dit que la gauche doit défendre le
travail et ne pas être la gauche des
allocations et des minima sociaux
comment vous réagir en attendant ses
propos
moi j'ai vu une forme de confusion
historique y compris par rapport au
combat de toujours du Parti communiste
français en fait quand on est de gauche
moi je suis écologiste m'empêche pas
d'être de gauche mais je suis avant tout
écologiste quand même il y a deux trois
trucs que j'ai compris c'est que dans
l'histoire des conquêtes sociales on
opposait pas le travail et les acquis
sociaux qui sont même imbriqués cette
même une différence fondamentale entre
l'analyse politique de la classe
ouvrière et du patronat
on oppose pas le travail et les allocs
la retraite les congés payés les minima
sociaux ils sont liés c'est ça qui
permet qui a un rapport de force entre
les salariés contre les détenteurs du
capital et dans un moment où ce rapport
de force n'a jamais été aussi faible
parce que la puissance capitale n'a
jamais été aussi puissance et il y a
plus besoin de la force de travail de
tout le monde donc on est pressé
d'ailleurs d'où l'ubérisation du travail
etc c'est très étonnant que le patron du
Parti communiste français semble épouser
la logique qui a toujours été celle de
la droite de culpabiliser les gens qui
travaillaient pas ça veut dire
l'assistanat
qui sont les bien sûr ce mot
d'assistanat était volé à la gauche qui
sont les assistés quand on voit les
profits dont on parlait justement qui
sont les assistés dans ce monde où on
subventionne les entreprises sans
condition et qu'on baisse le droit du
travail qu'on baisse faites alors moi je
suis écolo donc en plus le rapport au
travail j'ai sans doute pas le même
rapport à la valeur travail que la
gauche traditionnelle c'est un deuxième
débat mais moi je crois pas que le
travail fondamentalement
je pense que la vraie vie c'est pas
passer son temps à la gagner donc c'est
pour ça que je suis pour le partage du
travail le revenu universel le droit à
l'oisiveté même figurez-vous ça veut pas
dire que plus personne fout rien ça veut
dire que si on pense vraiment que le
travail a de la valeur on le on en use
avec parcimonie voilà vous êtes allé
voir les communistes ce week-end la Fête
de l'Huma oui on avait un stand pour la
première fois si vous êtes allé sur un
autre stand oui vous avez vu
chinois parce que le Parti communiste
chinois a un stand depuis toujours
d'ailleurs dans ce qu'on appelle le
village du monde ou un certain nombre de
parties frères du Parti communiste sont
présents dont et leur présence
indispensable tout à fait entre nous il
y a pas que le Parti communiste chinois
mais là il y a encore plus une actualité
par rapport à ce que se passe avec les
weoux vous avez vu qu'au début du mois
l'ONU a pointé à utiliser le terme de
crime contre l'humanité de la part du
régime chinois contre les Wiggs et voilà
il s'agissait pas de dire bah du coup on
y va pas parce qu'il y a pas de raison
c'est le fait de l'humanité à la partie
à tout le monde et vous demandez pas
partenaires communistes pardon parce
qu'on manifeste devant le Parti
communiste chinois j'en fais pas
l'injure d'avoir les mêmes positions que
le régime de Pékin mais en fait c'est ce
que j'ai essayé de dire en une formule
c'est qu'elle a fait de l'Huma oui les
crimes contre l'humanité n'ont et on ne
pouvait pas être dans un endroit de
discussion politique et festif sans dire
que là il y a des gens qui sont là qui
sont en train de faire un génocide et
donc interroger leur présence et ne pas
faire comme si on le voyait pas dire la
vérité enfin dire la vérité jusqu'à dire
ce qu'on pense le dire clairement je
pense que c'est aussi un service qu'on
se rend à toutes et tous il y a des
fraternités de parties qu'il faut
parfois savoir rompre
est-ce que Europe Écologie Les Verts
doit se remettre en question pour vous
David Corman comment expliquer vous que
malgré cette crise de conscience cette
crise et malgré le fait que la
conscience écologique soit de plus en
plus forte ça ne se traduit pas pour
vous dans les yeux vous en parlez dans
votre livre comment cette sensibilité
écologique produit un débouché politique
je vous cite oui mais c'est d'abord il
faut toujours se remettre en question
par rapport à votre question sur parce
que c'est
utile il y a un paradoxe c'est que que
vous venez de rappeler et je crois qu'il
est lié à un élément c'est quand
l'écologie politique n'est à la fin des
années 60 des années 70 puis avec le
Parti vert en 1984 on n'imagine pas une
seconde qu'on sera au pouvoir on se dit
on est là pour essayer de mettre sur la
table parlait tout à l'heure de la prise
de conscience pour être lanceur d'alerte
et uniquement lanceur d'alerte et au fil
du temps on a gagné une forme de
majorité culturelle pas pour nous mais
sur les questions écologiques et donc je
pense qu'il faut se remettre en question
et de changer d'objet social l'objet
social maintenant de l'écologie
politique c'est continuer à lancer
l'alerte et nous le faisons nous le
faisons bien c'est de continuer à
participer et c'est surtout s'organiser
pour gagner or l'objet parti Europe
Écologie Les Verts tel qu'il est calibré
aujourd'hui et encore très lié à son
histoire d'origine donc il faut changer
ça ça veut dire avoir moins de passion
pour les courants vous savez l'émotion
les courants qui régissent tout en fait
dans ce parti ça crée beaucoup de
dépenses énergétiques on parle beaucoup
d'efficacité énergétique donc là il y a
beaucoup de pertes en ligne où on
s'occupe de l'interne plutôt que
s'adresser à la société c'est un
problème être plus accueillant y compris
pour des personnes qui viennent taper
notre porte et nous on veut vous aider
on sait pas bien les accueillir c'est
trop fermé aujourd'hui
mais quand vous entrez vous venez dans
des réunions vous dites mais moi j'étais
pas venu pour ça j'étais venu pour
sauver la planète et on me parle de je
sais pas quoi des statuts du truc de
machin vous êtes concentré sur vous-même
décourage des bonnes volontés alors on
l'a fait pour des bonnes raisons c'est
l'hyper démocratie moi je suis très
respectueux de ça d'ailleurs je suis le
fruit quelque part donc je vais pas
dénigrer cela mais je j'ai envie de dire
à mes amis voilà ce que je suis en train
de dire ça s'adresse aux quelques
milliers d'adhérents élevés mais j'ai
envie les amis ayant confiance en nous
échangeons c'est le moment de le changer
on a besoin de nous parce qu'on voit
bien la tentation libérale la tentation
de l'extrême droite et la gauche telle
qu'elle est l'héritière de ce qu'elle a
été depuis un siècle et demi ne pourra
pas regagner c'est ma conviction pour
incarner ce changement oh nous on croit
l'incarnation collective vous le savez
je vais voter en touche diplomatiquement
mais je crois que d'abord il faut créer
l'outil politique une fois qu'on a un
antipolitique performant je pense que
les patients elle viendra qui succède à
Julien Bayon j'en sais rien ah bah là il
y a un congrès moi je soutiendrai marine
tondeuillier qui me paraît formidable
pour le job mais ça sera peut-être
quelqu'un d'autre on verra mais au-delà
de ces questions là il faut créer
l'outil partie qui permet d'accueillir
et grandir merci beaucoup d'avoir été
notre invité
[Musique]